Now it's time to construct
and preprocess the corpus.
So we'll start by loading the
tm package with library(tm).
And now that we'll
have done that,
we'll construct a variable
called corpus using the corpus
and vector source functions
and passing in all the emails
in our data set,
which is emails$email.
So now that we've
constructed the corpus,
we can output the first
email in the corpus.
We'll start out by calling
the strwrap function to get it
on multiple lines, and then we
can select the first element
in the corpus using the
double square bracket notation
and selecting element 1.
And we can see that
this is exactly
the same email that
we saw originally,
the email about
the working paper.
So now we're ready to preprocess
the corpus using the tm map
function.
So first, we'll
convert the corpus
to lowercase using tm map
and the two lower function.
So we'll have corpus =
tm_map(corpus, tolower).
And then we'll do the exact
same thing except removing
punctuation, so we'll have
corpus = tm_map(corpus,
removePunctuation).
We'll remove the stop words
with remove words function
and we'll pass along the stop
words of the English language
as the words we want to remove.
And lastly, we're going
to stem the document.
So corpus = tm_map(corpus,
stemDocument).
And now that we've gone through
those four preprocessing steps,
we can take a second look at
the first email in the corpus.
So again, call
strwrap(corpusstrwrap(corpus{[1]).
And now it looks
quite a bit different.
We can come up to the top here.
It's a lot harder to
read now that we removed
all the stop words and
punctuation and word stems,
but now the emails
in this corpus
are ready for our machine
learning algorithms.